all right here we go
[Music]
all right everybody
here we are can you believe it
it's november 4th the election was
yesterday
the election continues into today the
election
will continue tomorrow the day after
tomorrow
the day after the day after tomorrow and
in perpetuity this
is our lives and we're gonna live it
forever now
um there's so much to talk about and i
just wanna
set the table let me just set the table
with you guys right now
i'm going to try to take a bit of a
light tone today with all of this
i try to give you the news in an easily
digestible somewhat pleasant format
but i'm really going to double down on
that today because first off despite
all of the insanity and there is a hell
of a lot of insanity
i am feeling pretty good about things uh
perhaps more than anything else that so
many people actually took part in the
process so many people
care and sure there's a lot of people
that are trying to manipulate that
process right now and we got major
problems ahead
but we also got it out of the way and
even though it's still here it's still
sitting with us it's like we did finish
the voting part at least for now and i
think that that's kind of good
and life goes on and you're not going to
believe this people but i also do think
about other things besides politics and
i i suppose and i hope that you do as
well
and there are more important things out
there but
this is obviously important uh
everyone's sort of going bananas
we've got the charts the updated charts
here we're going to show them to you
and then i was scribbling down some
things right before we started
i tried to beat myself at tic-tac-toe
could not do it i cannot beat myself at
tic-tac-toe amazing right
so look you know we're i don't have the
fake glasses today
uh because i'm just i'm just going
straight to you uh but we're gonna talk
about a lot of stuff
uh including a video that i'll get to in
a second
where i kind of predicted the whole the
whole damn thing but before we do that
guys are you looking for a new protein
bar
that tastes like candy well i've got one
for you i've got the brand
for you and it's in my hand right now
built bars are super tasty and come in
18
amazing flavors my personal favorite is
right here it's the cookies and cream
bill bars are covered in 100 chocolate
and include both
nut and nut free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew
with the holidays just around the corner
it's easy to slip up which is why build
bars are the perfect alternative
to the pie for the health conscious guy
how about that for a rhyme
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a delicious treat
built bars are low calorie low sugar
high protein and high fiber go to
billboard.com and use promo code ruben
and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at billbar.com good for bars built
go or
built boost and now back to me
all right so i think the main takeaway
no matter what happens right now
is the pollsters and the mainstream
media
and the media elite and the new york
times
and the networks that they're all wrong
and we
really should stop listening to them as
i said last night i don't want to put
these people in jail i don't want to put
them in gulags
well i can't say i don't want to but i
don't plan on doing it
no i don't want to do that and that is
not the american way to jail your
political
opponents at least for now um
but some people need to be ignored the
people who for weeks have been telling
us that this thing was going to be a
blowout
and the margins were bigger than last
time and they got it all wrong last time
but this time they weren't getting it
wrong
and all of these things they got
everything wrong again because this is
way closer as a matter of fact trump
might win i still think that's quite
likely
um so it's way closer and even the
little things about minorities and
things things that they said could never
happen
actually did happen so we're going to
unpack some of the numbers and we'll get
into all that and i'll give you the i'll
give you the latest updates
but i want to throw to a clip of
something that i did
on monday with glenn beck i was on glenn
beck's podcast for about an hour
dissecting everything that we thought
could happen would and could happen in
the election
and glenn asked me about what could
happen on election night
if it was getting kind of close and
dare i pat myself on the back but let's
go to the video
well there's so many ways to think about
this that some of them i don't even want
to voice because i don't want to even
add add energy to it but one of the ones
that i've been thinking about is what
happens if on election night
the powers that be at abc cbs nbc cnn
etc let's say things are really coming
in close
but in the old days where it was like oh
it's it's three points that actually is
a lot three points towards trump
you call it you call it we've done our
due diligence you call it
well what if there's i'm not saying
they're sitting in a room in a dark room
with evil laughter necessarily
but the idea being that most of these
people obviously are democrats they're
media elite they
they don't want to give up their power
why wouldn't they be on the phone going
you know what
we're actually just not going to call
florida yeah it's three points on trump
but we're not going to really say that
or so or we're just not going to call it
and then abc doesn't call it then nbc
doesn't call it
then cnn doesn't call it so i'm worried
about that layer it's it's not just
voter fraud in terms of the number
it's actually the numbers translating
into what the media will then
communicate with us i'm actually more
worried about that so we
man it is going to be a crazy week
the guy you're listening to right there
is dave rubin
election prediction expert
extraordinaire yeah
i don't have the fancy numbers and a
team of data scientists
and all of that stuff that nate silver
over at 538
has did you see that guy on abc last
night my god he looked like he got hit
by a truck
these people just you keep getting
everything wrong and for
some reason the pundit class keeps going
back to you guys but
in essence what i said there was that if
this thing was close
what would stop the networks
and the machinery from calling it if it
wasn't going in the way that it wanted
now i'm not officially saying that's
exactly
what happened here okay but you can't
say
it's not sort of in the realm of what is
true and certainly
in the ballpark of what is possible so
i was on live with the daily wire guys
and i was on at about 5
30 p.m that was so that's pacific time
so about 8 30
p.m eastern and at that time it was
still
very up in the air there was no sense it
was going either way it was all sort of
shaking out the way it was supposed to
by about 7 30 pacific so now this is
about
uh 10 30 eastern time suddenly there was
real momentum like
the trump thing was starting to work it
was starting to work and there was a
real feeling like holy cow this really
is happening and then suddenly it looked
like michigan
and wisconsin and georgia and
pennsylvania it looked like they were
all going to go trump
and then by about 8 30 or so i did my
life no i did my live stream here at
about 8 30
pacific so by about 9 30 pacific
suddenly
the voting just seemed to have stopped
in all of these places i didn't know
that that was a thing suddenly people
had to go home they couldn't count votes
anymore this is
the most important election of a
generation of a lifetime ever
people got to take naps also um it all
got very bizarre that it seemed to all
happen at the exact same time and then i
think it was at about 11
p.m pacific joe biden came out gave
about a four minute speech he stumbled
and bumbled made a
really weird remark at the end got a
little confused as to who the governor
of
delaware was uh and then and then left
the stage
and then trump came out about a half
hour later and in essence
said we won um and you gotta
he made a mistake so here's what this is
this is one of the things that where
trump and language
get a little screwy and then you you
throw in a dishonest media and you have
a problem
trump in essence said you don't go ahead
and count more votes
now what he meant and i i would bet
anything on this what he meant was you
don't count votes that shouldn't count
not that you shouldn't continue counting
all of the legitimate votes
but that's sort of like a trump sort of
you know he makes these broad statements
and then you have to whittle it into
something
but i could see someone watching this
right now i can see one of you watching
this right now and say dave don't give
him
the leash on that that it seems to me
that that's what he was saying i don't
think that the president of the united
states
was saying don't count legitimate votes
but i saw a million people in the media
saying the fascist
has arrived he doesn't want us to finish
the election and everything else
um now the problem is that many of these
states
michigan pennsylvania a couple of the
others
they've got democratic governors now
that means that they have democratic
administrations that
most likely the machinery in those
states probably want biden to win
that's exactly what i was talking about
with glenn beck on monday
that a conspiracy isn't just you know
it's not just the the evil
guys and the simpsons laughing in the
room you know it's not just that
but that it sort of moves and morphs and
kind of happens in real time
and suddenly as they it seems that as
they kind of realized that trump really
was going to win and the numbers weren't
looking good
well then suddenly they just started
shutting down these states as if that's
something that we do
on election night i mean that that isn't
something we do but i do know we live
in a time with with no rules so i
suppose anything is possible so i want
to give you guys a quick update and then
we'll talk a little bit about the media
coverage
as well uh as of right now trump is up
by about 500 000 in pennsylvania so that
looks pretty
pretty solid apparently they have to
vote they have to do some
counting in the philadelphia area that
could go more blue you know big cities
tend to go more blue
but the chances that they make up 500
probably not great that's what 66
percent in
in michigan biden is up 50 which is
pretty negligible at 96 percent in so
that clearly could go either way
but biden technically is in the lead
biden's up 20 000 in wisconsin which is
absolutely nothing and i'm pretty sure
that the trump administration has
already said
they're going to demand a recount there
that's with 95 percent in
and then the other two big ones at the
moment uh trump is up by 80 000 votes in
georgia
not a tremendous amount uh but that's
with 95 percent in
and trump is up 80 000 votes as well
with 94
in in north carolina so that's kind of
where we stand at the moment and if
if the recounts are happening right now
and there are no shenanigans then
hopefully we will have some answers i
mean nobody wants this thing
well let me not say nobody most people
don't want this thing to last
past today right um i think most people
wanted it to wrap up last night and
and let me just be very clear on this if
the numbers had come back
and it was clear that joe biden had won
well you guys know i wanted trump to win
and i still want trump to win right i
think that is the
i think he is the leader for this
time this bizarre time we lead in he is
we live in he is the guy
that can lead us most effectively if you
care about the things that i care about
so i'm putting my cards on the table
here right i'm not
i'm not hiding behind anything like
everyone on network news does
as if they have no opinions about any of
these things meanwhile
you know i'm watching abc news last
night and it's anchored by i keep
telling you this george stephanopoulos
former
clinton staffer and who's he's sitting
next to but uh rahm emanuel former
clinton staffer and then they've got all
democrats around him and then chris
christie's there now he's a big guy so
maybe he counts as a couple republicans
but it's like in essence you you guys
you like that one michael liked that one
um so okay so
i'm putting my cards on the table so i'm
telling you i i do want trump to win but
if the numbers came back
and it was an obvious bite and win then
i would have absolutely accepted
that accepted that last night and then i
would have had to do an
autopsy on what i talk about here and
maybe did i see something wrong or
whatever but in essence
the things that i've been talking about
here this election because of the really
high numbers
for trump um in essence this is this is
a win
for the future of the republican party i
think either way because they started to
get more diverse which we'll get into
in a minute and and the numbers really
did go up so
so that is good but here's the question
now it's what i said to glenn
how do we trust the machine right now
like you watching this right now
do you trust the machine do you trust
that philadelphia which is
in pennsylvania obviously that those
people there democratic run
philadelphia in a democratic-run state
by a attorney general with an attorney
general
this shapiro guy not not ben shapiro
different shapiro that's the good
shapiro this is the bad shapiro
who literally said days ago and we we
talked about it the other day
uh that that biden will win pennsylvania
that's what he said before election day
that's what the attorney general
of pennsylvania said so do you trust the
machinery meaning the
the machinery the political machinery of
pennsylvania which happens to be
democratic
do you trust them to to actually count
the votes honestly
if they feel like they can actually flip
the election which they potentially have
the power to do
and then do you at the secondary level
do you trust what i was talking about
with glenn do you
trust the media elites who all
want this guy out do you trust them to
do the right thing
as i said before it's not a conspiracy
to say i don't think these people are
fully trustworthy
i don't think that's a conspiracy theory
right so if you're if you're out there
right now and
and you're confused and you're not
totally sure who to trust
and you think the system's a little
whacked you're you're that means you're
you're kind of thinking right now like
everybody else that's just like get me
the numbers and i want the numbers and
the numbers better
be what i want them to be and that's how
it's going to be and it's like come on
man like
that that's not what we're doing here
you see what i just i just did the biden
right come on man
that was my biden impression right there
um
so i think that that sort of trust level
is is a huge problem that we've got
right now and i don't know how we get
past it so my hope
here's my hope right now my hope is that
out of the states that i just write off
to you michigan
pennsylvania wisconsin georgia and north
carolina
if we can get results that that are
tangible
results from those states then we can
probably declare a winner today it
doesn't sound
like it's going to happen i mean even
you could even see on abc especially
last night
the entire time they were teasing oh
we're going to need a week for this
we're going to need a week for this
and the thing is you guys know this
remember two weeks to flatten the curve
that's what the the establishment told
us back in march
about covid now we're eight months later
right
so when they tell you oh we need a week
to figure this out well before you know
it it's six months
before you know it we're fighting this
thing out in the supreme court right
before
the new president or the the returning
president is supposed to be sworn in on
january 20th
so we got a we got a big set of problems
but in essence
i think what trump did last night was he
basically drew a line in the sand he
said first off i'm gonna
i'm gonna fight he said we're winning in
these key states we've got these numbers
here
we think we're gonna win them and by the
way that's what biden said too so
they're both
in essence saying the same thing we're
losing here we're winning here but we
think we're gonna win we think we're
gonna win okay that's fine that's just
politics
but but what in essence trump said he
did say the f word right he said
he said the fraud word so that's number
one um
but he also basically drew a line in the
sand and made it clear
that if they feel that there are
shenanigans
and that's a legitimate fear that is not
calling the election into question
that is a legitimate fear uh well then
in that case
that then they'll go to the courts now
do we want this thing going to the
courts if
i mean if this thing goes to the courts
that means it's worked its way through
the system
the states have made decisions we're not
totally sure if those decisions were
right and then we got to get this thing
all the way to the supreme court knowing
that trump put in
three of these people knowing how
contentious that is i mean maybe it
feels like it's all just supposed to go
that way
because because the energy of the
universe or something is just
is just dragging us that way but but i
hope that is not what happens i hope
that maybe there are some elected
officials in these states
who care about getting it right more
than getting their guy
in and you know you can't be bringing in
votes that weren't postmarked by
election day and you can't be doing
all of this random stuff you know there
was this there was this uh
image going around twitter this morning
of apparently
a hundred thousand extra votes that
magically appeared
in michigan for biden overnight so
meaning biden's number went up by a
hundred thousand from the time they
stopped counting
until the morning but trump's didn't
move now that's mathematically
impossible it is
literally impossible and i'm not using
the word literally figuratively i'm
using it literally
that uh biden or trump but in this case
biden could get a hundred thousand votes
with the competitor
getting zero votes now they're saying
that somebody actually made a mistake
and they forgot to put a one in there
and it's closer to like 15
000 votes for biden not not a hundred
thousand but like this sort of stuff
is what we're just going to keep hearing
more of and and the unfortunate part is
it makes people
worry it makes people go man is the
system strong enough to
to withstand this stuff is it is it
trustworthy enough
i don't know exactly what the answer is
i i don't think anyone knows exactly
what the answer is
and and i certainly don't think that
anyone watching mainstream media is
going to get anything saying i mean
whatever you
do i hope you give me a couple minutes
of your day right like that that's
wonderful and this thing's really
growing and i guess i've carved out a
nice little space in that
um but you should not be sitting at home
you know we're all sitting at home
because these stupid lockdowns
you should not have cnn on all day and i
don't even mean that just to make fun of
cnn it's easy to make fun of cnn
you shouldn't have any of these channels
on all day waiting every minute for the
breaking news of the
this state operative said that
he forgot to carry the wand and this
guy's going there and they postmarked
this like
it will make you crazy so try not to do
it i don't know if you come here for
life advice but try not to do it i don't
even have cable anymore
so we don't keep those channels on but
but if you want to be engaged in this
it's like yeah you can check in every
couple hours flip through twitter
see what's on your facebook feed and the
rest of it so that you're aware of
what's happening but but don't be
sucked in at that level the idea that
we're all trapped at home now and then
we're watching all of this stuff more
and it's designed to make us all crazy
and and make us hyper partisan and
everything else it's it's kind of
dangerous
um all right so let's let's step away
though from like the specifics of what
happened because it's going to keep
unfolding and i promise you i will i
will do my best
to communicate whatever the truth is to
you whether i like it or not
uh i want to move on to uh to two
stories here that have to do with race
because it turns out that in a lot of
the exit polls and and i'm not a huge
fan of exit polls the idea
that someone walks out after voting and
there's an exit pollster there
and they ask them you know what who they
voted for and what are the issues they
care about whatever
it's like if someone approached me as i
walked out of the booth the other day i
would have been like
go f yourself like i i don't need to
talk to you you know what i mean like
it's my business
that's it i'm a public person in
disregard
um so i don't like the idea of it and we
know that people mess with
with pollsters scott adams has talked a
lot about this how especially trump
people
you know you're kind of closeted about
your trump support depending on where
you live
you're not going to just walk out of the
thing and then just like tell a random
person what you think about everything
um but the but from the exit polls it
does seem uh that there was a real
minority shift and now we're seeing this
in actual
voting numbers that are coming out now
that there was a real shift in
in the minority vote uh but that is very
unfortunate for the people that trade in
race all day long and
in essence this is really what the the
lefty establishment
does it's pretty much all they've got so
joy reid who is a host on msnbc who is
not a good person i'm sorry she's just
not she has written a lot of anti-gay
stuff from years ago that apparently was
hacked into her computer and then
everyone just dropped it because she's a
lefty but if
she was on the right she would have been
canceled um she's
she's sort of the worst kind of partisan
thing and trades in just making
it seem like everyone is racist well
watch this clip from
joy reid on msnbc last night
but if somehow they managed to stumble
into the supreme court
do any of you guys trust uncle clarence
and amy coney barrett and those guys to
actually
follow the letter of the law no i mean
it is a completely
politicized supreme
you want to know what modern racism is
guys that
there are no people out there that don't
think black people
should be allowed to use the same water
fountains everyone believes that
virtually everyone in the united states
wants equality
and doesn't care what your skin color is
and doesn't care what your gender is and
in most cases doesn't even care what
your sexuality is okay that is a fact
that doesn't mean that there aren't
fringe weirdos that don't think those
things but they have no power
that is a host of a 24-hour cable news
network using a slur
okay using a slur uncle clarence you see
what she's getting at there right it
start it's a name that starts with the t
that's three letters that if i say if i
say the phrase uncle blank
if i say it we know that this video
automatically gets demonetized
automatically the the way the system
works they'll find me
saying it they will demonetize it i
don't even care about the money but what
that will then do is hurt it in the
algorithm and then less people will see
it
she just used a racial slur imagine
imagine if a conservative did what she
just did media matters and
all of these lefty loonies would be
calling for whoever's head it is
but somehow the anti-racists the
anti-racists of the left are actually
allowed
to be the most racist towards black
people
so joy reid if you are watching this you
are a racist
you're a genuine racist you are a modern
racist
and good luck with that and i have no
doubt that you'll continue at msnbc but
of course
joy reid is not the only modern racist
uh jemele hill who you may remember
she was at espn and then went crazy woke
on him well
she tweeted this
if trump wins reelection it's on white
people no one else
white people no one else well now first
off
jamal um white people are entitled to
their opinions
white people are allowed to vote for
whoever their conscience dictates just
like black people
and asian people and all other people
everyone's allowed to vote for who they
think
now the funny thing of course of what
she said here and she's one of the prime
purveyors of just
trading in race all day long she's
become super successful in the most
patriarchal racist
society ever i saw her once in the at
lax airport she was walking with michael
jordan not michael jordan
chicago bulls michael jordan the actor
michael b jordan who played creed
right and they were walking together and
he's you know pimped out in his fancy
outfit
and she's in some crazy outfit with
these furry shoes and like the furry
shoes were clearly
a lot of dough so she's doing okay in
this deeply racist state i don't have
furry shoes
i don't want furry shoes but i wouldn't
even know where to get furry shoes
the point is she's doing okay here but
they trade
in racism that no longer exists
but don't even take my word for it let's
look at some of the numbers because
they're actually pretty fascinating and
you're not going to believe this guys
let's pull up the numbers donald trump
you know mr
mr hitler nazi white supremacist donald
trump
he just got the highest share of the
non-white
vote for the republicans since 1960
so if you just quickly run through these
numbers in 1960
they got 32 percent of non-white voters
and then it's been pretty messy and
depressing since then
it bottomed out four years later it went
from 32
to 6 i mean that's that's actually
incredible and then it was sort of 12
and 13 15
10 13 18 a little higher 11 12 9 17
10 11 and then in 2016
okay and this is trump's first time
around it actually went up a bit right
so we went up 10 points
okay in 2016 and then it went up another
at least it's preliminary at the moment
but it went up another five points
so that means in the two elections that
donald trump has taken place in
2016 and 2020 that means that non-white
vote for the republicans has actually
gone
up 15 that is pretty amazing and
it makes you think that no these people
aren't
all uncle whatever and that the election
of donald trump the first time and
potentially the second time isn't just
on
white people but if you want to just
live in your depressed reality then i
suppose
you can go ahead and do it um okay guys
so i'm gonna jump for now
uh there's obviously a lot going on i
got a couple other podcasts that i'm
doing it's obviously going to be
a bit of a haywire week we're going to
be going five days a week here for a
while you know originally when i started
doing this direct message thing we said
three days a week tuesday through
thursday
but there's obviously so much going on
and the reaction's been so fantastic and
i'm actually loving doing this
and i think we're we're doing something
important throughout the chaos
that uh we're gonna do it five days a
week and if things really break today
i'll come back and we'll do another live
stream and all that
as always if you want to communicate
with me directly join us at
rubinreport.com
which by the way i put out a link to
rubenreport.com today on twitter
and twitter it was warning people that
uh
that it could be a fraudulent website
and that it may be giving fake news
something to that effect i i tweeted the
the screenshot of that
um so you know our big tech overlords
they're always up to something anyway uh
stay calm
we're gonna get through this thing one
way or another and and i
i still i'm feeling confident i'm
feeling good about everything
and even if even if it doesn't go the
way i want it to go if if we get through
this in an honest sensible way and
that's a big if
then everything everything will be okay
and if not let's build a bunker or let's
build a rocket and let's get the hell
out of here so we've got options okay
have a good day everybody